moi je pense qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
deux ministres qui soit en charge d'une
collectivité que c'est que le premier
ministre et le président de la
république d'aller stricte de la règle
oui ils ne l'accepteront bien entendu
pas et donc le souhait que je forme pour
2016 c'est que jean yves le drian reste
ministre de la défense et que nous ayons
en décembre 2015 conserver la région
bretagne où vous ne souhaitez pas qui
mène la campagne en tête de liste en
région bretagne je pense que jean yves
le drian est assez identifiés pour être
présents dans cette campagne sans être
en position de devenir président de la
région mais c'est à lui de le dire il
l'annoncera je pense dans quelques jours
mais ce que je souhaite bien entendu
c'est qu'ils puissent continuer à
apporter vous savez les faits de sa
diplomatie de sa capacité à comprendre
de sa capacité à agir vous êtes assure
déjà il est très proche de jean louis
joseph est bien cette décision non les
acteurs parents je pense que sur un
sujet comme ça il en discutera jusqu'au
dernier moment avec le président de la
république